Il suolo è la cenerentola del capitale
naturale ma che l'acqua Ma che è l'aria
il suolo Eppure il suolo è legato allo
Sporco Mi sono divertita Prima di venire
qua a guardare un po' la parola suolo in
inglese
perché molti documenti sul suolo sono in
inglese soil è uguale ad Earth è un
sinonimo di sporco Don sold Your Clothes
non ti sporcare i tuoi vestiti quante
volte siete andati al parco Le mamme
cosa dicono Tira via le mani dalla terra
non ti sporcare volevo venire con delle
scarpe sporche per farvi vedere che in
un pugno di terra in realtà se la
prendiamo in mano la terra la sentiamo
profuma la terra il suolo contiene un
quarto Delle specie viventi
un quarto Delle specie viventi che però
sono un pochino bruttarelle
e contiene in un pugno di suolo abbiamo
più abitanti nel mondo lo sapevate io io
l'ho scoperto
volevo citarvi Mi sono portato i fogli
perché non mi ricordo le cose il
responsabile dell'ufficio dell'Unione
Europea per il suolo Luca Montanelli un
italiano dice che il suolo è una grande
macchina che ricicla tutto
e chi lo ricicla Questi signori Questi
signori che non sono i gattini cagnolini
tutto rispetto ma sono i collemboli gli
acari i diplotidi una miriade di
microrganismi piccoli pensate che la
talpa è uno dei pochi vertebrati che
vive nel suolo tutti gli altri sono
questi signori qua
oggettivamente un po' bruttarelli un po'
bruttarelli ma fondamentali
complessivo il sistema suolo vi Cito una
frase di Leonardo che dice che
conosciamo di più dei movimenti celesti
che del suolo che sotto i nostri piedi
effettivamente lo pestiamo tutti i
giorni cosa ci importa invece ci importa
il suolo è vita
e il sole vita Lo so che è una frase un
po' banale ma lo è vi dirò una serie di
motivi per cui il suono è vita il 95%
del cibo che consumiamo è prodotto dal
suolo dalle piante Il suolo è
fondamentale per produrre
le risorse naturali molte medicine
vengono dal suolo le estraiamo l'acqua
la regimazione delle acque il flusso
delle acque inoltre il suolo è la culla
della biodiversità la biodiversità è una
parola chiave del nostro periodo una
parola fondamentale perché la perdita
della biodiversità rompe l'equilibrio di
quei piccoli operai brutti che vivono
nel buio Ma che lavorano per noi quindi
non c'è vita senza suono
non c'è vita senza suolo ma soprattutto
il suolo è un buffer enorme per aiutarci
nel cambiamento climatico pensate che il
suolo raccoglie stocca naturalmente più
sostanza organica dell'aria quando
pensiamo a cambiamenti climatici a me
viene da pensare all'atmosfera la CO2
Dov'è nell'atmosfera No la CO2 è
Soprattutto negli oceani ma anche nel
suolo e il suolo questo ruolo
fondamentale così come stocca e
ricordiamo questo questo è importante
dirlo Il suolo è vecchio il suolo è una
fonte di saggezza e di vecchiaia fare 3
mm di suolo ci vogliono 100 anni
però se noi
pensiamo a
lo 0,1% del carbonio del suolo un numero
piccolissimo vero
dissipare lo 0,1% del carbonio del suolo
equivale a
bruciare l'equivalente in CO2 di 100
milioni di macchine mi dà un po' l'idea
dell'importanza del suolo e del ruolo
che ha nel cambiamento climatico adesso
ci facciamo una domanda Come sta questo
suolo
Allora se fosse una persona Mi viene da
dire che bene bene bene bene non sta
l'attività umana i cambiamenti climatici
lo hanno eroso consumato impoverito
questo Cosa significa vi dico due numeri
due numeri interessanti
la Fao che l'organizzazione mondiale per
l'alimentazione e per l'agricoltura ci
dice che ad oggi il 33% un terzo dei
suoi mondiali sono degradati e se
continuiamo così
Business is usual loro dicono al 2050 in
90 per cento dei suoli sarà degradato
e avere questo degrado potrà portare
alla sparizione di un 10% Delle specie
che ci danno da mangiare Magari non
proprio quelle però altre che altro il
2,5 miliardi di persone soffrono per gli
effetti del degrado del suolo e ancora
se continuiamo col Business siusual l'8%
della popolazione mondiale sarà nel 2050
colpita dalla fame Mica poco eh in
Europa non va meglio in Europa il 60-70
per cento dei suoli sono non stanno bene
diciamo che non stanno benissimo se
scendiamo dove stiamo adesso
nell'Europa meridionale il 25 per cento
dei suoli tende alla desertificazione
perché quella cosa molto bella che ci si
mettono 100 anni a fare la sostanza
organica se ne sta andando a meno 0,
95% all'anno suoli di pianura fertili Ok
mi sembra di avervi detto abbastanza
cose negative perché arriviamo ci sono
le soluzioni Credo di sì le soluzioni ci
sono c'è la scienza c'è la tecnologia
E soprattutto
allontaniamoci da un modello di economia
lineare dissipativo che prende una
risorsa la sfrutta e provoca produce
Inquinamento e rifiuto ci sono forme di
economia a forme di economia spinte
anche a livello politico dell'Unione
Europea l'economia circolare la
bioeconomia che la prima l'economia
circolare Mima i processi naturali
quindi Mima questi equilibri questa
chiusura del cerchio vi Cito ancora
perché mi piaceva questa frase una frase
del 1971 di
un ecologo americano che anche
partecipato
informazioni politiche mi viene e ha
preso lo 0,27% in America però
era è molto bravo come ecologo in ogni
sistema naturale ciò che viene eliminato
da un organismo come rifiuto viene
utilizzato da un altro come cibo
chiudiamo il ciclo
benissimo teniamo in mente questo e
pensiamo invece alla bioeconomia la
bioeconomia invece è un'economia che usa
le sostanze naturali le risorse naturali
il mare la terra i rifiuti per produrre
cibo mangimi per produrre energia vi
porto due esempi
casalinghi direi di come ognuno di noi
può partecipare
all'economia circolare alla bioeconomia
il compost ognuno di voi se siete novasi
Ma immagino anche non novaresi perché
dal 2022 la raccolta differenziata
dell'organico è obbligatoria è un attore
della bioeconomia circolare nel momento
in cui raccoglie in maniera pulita
dentro il suo bidoncino dell'organico
con sacchetti che mimano e sono prodotti
dalla bioeconomia
raccolgono il rifiuto organico che va in
un impianto di personaggio viene
trasformato in quella sostanza organica
che è un ammendante in compost che viene
portato nei campi dove contribuisce a
ricreare quegli equilibri e a sostenere
tutti quei piccoli operai che sono sotto
i nostri piedi e che ci garantiscono un
solo fertile Questo è il primo esempio
quindi possiamo dire che anche noi
singolarmente possiamo
contribuire alla
mitigazione
un altro esempio che vi voglio portare
sono le plastiche il suolo riceve un
terzo di tutti i rifiuti plastici dalle
5 alle 23 volte di più dei mari esistono
in Europa 30% delle plastiche usate in
agricoltura non ha raccolto ancora una
volta c'è la possibilità di usare la
tecnologia di usare elementi strumenti
mimetici di quello che fanno di quello
che succede in natura
per ridurre gli effetti permanenti delle
plastiche quali per esempio le
pacciamature biodegradabili
l'ultima cosa che vi voglio dire sul
degrado del suolo non è tanto legato al
suo inquinamento ma il consumo voglio
proprio dirlo qua a Novara perché Novara
in Piemonte è la provincia dove c'è il
più alto consumo di suolo pari all'11%
neanche Torino Torino arriva l'8:05 e vi
dirò di più secondo i dati Ispra Novara
nel 2021 è insieme a Chieti a Pescara la
provincia in cui si ha un tasso di
incremento di perdita del suolo 1% nel
resto
dell'Italia lo 0-3%. anche qua come
cittadini possiamo avere coscienza di
questi dati
Ok arriviamo alla cosiddetta gonews la
Good news è che dal 2021 L'Unione
Europea ha deciso di includere il suolo
questo malato nella in una strategia
globale vedete che il suolo è circondato
dalle altre politiche europee perché
proprio per questa sua varietà enorme di
funzioni il suolo un suolo sano può
aiutare nei cambiamenti climatici può
ridurre gli inquinamenti può aiutare
anche nella biodiversità quindi la
strategia del suolo è la strategia che
al 2050 si va intersecare con tutte le
altre strategie dell'Unione Europea a
livello ambientale per supportare questo
valore naturale
concretamente poi è stato messo il suolo
all'interno di una delle cinque missioni
dell'Unione Europea cosa sono le
missioni sono delle proprio come una
come la missione Apollo sulla luna
l'applicazione di tecnologia e di
scienza per risolvere sfide e una delle
sfide il suolo una delle mie azioni è la
missione suolo che si propone al 2030 di
riportarla alla fertilità al 75% dei
suoli europei anche attraverso nuove
forme di governance nuove forme di
dialogo tra gli scienziati e il mondo
civile e i cittadini i cittadini hanno
un ruolo fondamentale perché devono
sapere che quello su cui camminano tutti
i giorni è un patrimonio naturale
vi saluto Quindi con
una buona notizia Speriamo che la nostra
Cenerentola possa andare al ballo e
grazie
[Applauso]